cómo
[Música]
aumentan las víctimas fatales y las
tensiones en el conflicto entre
palestina e israel la franja de gaza ha
muerto 43 personas incluidos 13 niños y
5 en israel desde el lunes tel aviv ha
respondido con más de 500 bombardeos a
los más de 1000 cohetes lanzados desde
gaza
la comunidad internacional instala
desescalada de ambos lados
en colombia está convocada para hoy una
nueva jornada de huelga nacional contra
el gobierno del presidente duque quien
desde la ciudad de cali epicentro de
estas protestas a nivel nacional
prometió investigar denuncias de abuso
policial durante marchas denuncio
gratuidad para la educación superior
india sobrepasó las 254 mil muertes por
kobe 19 y batió un nuevo récord de
muertes en un día con 4 mil 205
fallecidos un nueva delhi una de las
ciudades más castigadas por la falta de
oxígeno en los hospitales para tratar a
los pacientes con coronavirus más graves
contabilizó 2.480 nuevos contagios y 347
decesos en las últimas 24 horas
[Música]
muy buen día gracias por continuar con
nosotros en france 24 su revelan como
siempre un gusto acompañarlos comenzamos
con la escalada de tensión que se vive
en medio oriente entre palestina e
israel los ataques mutuos no se habían
visto desde el último reconocimiento de
las hostilidades en el año 2014 el grupo
hamas que controla la franja de gaza
confirmó que en las últimas horas lanzó
130 cohetes contra tel aviv luego de que
el ejército israelí bombardeó un
edificio de tres servicios en casa el
grupo armado palestino ya había
amenazado con disparar hacia la urbe
israelí si su ejército cumplía la
advertencia de atacar la conocida
edificación que contenía una oficina
civil del grupo hamas desde el lunes
israel le ha respondido con más de 500
bombardeos a los más de 1000 cohetes
disparados desde casa
entretanto hoy se reportan 43 muertos
incluidos 13 niños en casa y cinco
israelíes ante esta escalada se siguen
sumando las voces de la comunidad
internacional para un cese de estas
hostilidades según el ministro de
defensa israelí y sólo habrá tregua
haya una calma duradera y el presidente
rubén rivlin aseguró que en las ciudades
árabes israelíes se está llevando a cabo
un pogromo que son ataques de odio
contra judíos
debemos actuar contra todos aquellos que
intentan atacar a los ciudadanos
israelíes o al estado de israel
tienen a ciudadanos policías queman
casas autos sinagogas es obvio que no
podemos aceptar esto en ningún país lo
aceptará y desde luego nosotros
comprobamos y es que israel no se ha
visto tan afectada por los ataques
palestinos gracias a la famosa cúpula de
hierro israelí un sistema de tecnología
que intercepta los misiles que llegan
desde gaza a que les explicamos cómo
funcionan
es una vista familiar en el cielo del
sur de israel una descarga de misiles
llegan desde gaza la mayoría
interceptados antes de que lleguen al
suelo como a quien telaviv la noche del
martes
en sexting más de 60 misiles disparados
hacia tel aviv se interceptaron con la
cúpula de hierro en la cúpula de hierro
es el único sistema de emisión dual en
el mundo que proporciona una efectiva
solución de defensa a los misiles vi en
models desarrollado por empresas de
israelíes con apoyo de eeuu la cúpula de
hierro está específicamente designada
para contrarrestar misiles de corto
alcance como los que llegan desde gaza
tiene un 90% de éxito y es relativamente
barato usando radares y programas de
análisis solo intercepta misiles que son
una amenaza
pero solo hacen falta unos centenares de
cohetes domésticos para aterrorizar a la
gente
ashkelón es una de las ciudades donde no
se pudieron evitar las muertes
fue uno de los trescientos cohetes
disparados desde gaza israel
afortunadamente la cúpula de hierro
interceptó más de 90% de los misiles
pero desafortunadamente uno
estos punteros sistema antimisiles han
cambiado la vida de mucha gente en el
sur de israel y han aliviado la presión
sobre el ejército además de convertirse
en una industria importante
contribuyendo a las crecientes
exportaciones de defensa del país pero
los críticos recuerdan que antes que
confiarse en la tecnología el gobierno
debería hacer más para solucionar la
raíz del conflicto con diplomacia
[Aplausos]
y cambiamos ahora de información en
colombia se cumplen 15 días de
manifestaciones ciudadanas y el país se
prepara para una nueva jornada de paro
nacional prevista para hoy miércoles 12
de mayo el presidente iván duque viajó a
la ciudad de cali epicentro de estas
protestas ciudadanas allí sostuvo
encuentros con autoridades locales y su
equipo negociador desplegado allí para
buscar una salida a esta crisis social
duke prometió investigar denuncias de
abuso policial durante marchas y aseguró
que ocho de los casos son homicidios
atribuidos a policías durante la
represión a los manifestantes también
anunció gratuidad para la educación
superior universitaria técnica y
tecnológica para los más pobres durante
el segundo semestre 2021 por otro lado
son al menos siete reclamos sobre los
que giran las conversaciones y
peticiones del comité y los sindicatos
la principal una renta básica para los
más vulnerables cuyo costo anual
superaría los 73 millones de pesos unos
23.000 millones de dólares en qué
consisten estas exigencias y cuál es su
viabilidad marina sardenya
en el informe
el comité nacional del paro sostiene sus
propuestas económicas y sociales que
buscan soluciones a la crisis política y
social que ha causado las protestas y se
ha visto agravada por la pandemia de
kobe 19 abanderadas por una renta básica
de emergencia para 6 millones de hogares
en condición de pobreza y vulnerabilidad
por un período de seis meses pues yo
considero que las peticiones que hace el
comité de paro son peticiones racionales
y podemos ver que más de las peticiones
están reflejando lo que es lo que está
pidiendo la la sociedad colombiana en
este momento hay un problema de déficits
sociales que no ha sido resuelto no ha
sido resuelto
durante los últimos 20 25 años que se ha
mantenido una estabilidad macroeconómica
las propuestas tendrían un costo
aproximado de 81 billones de pesos
anuales según cálculos de economistas
locales la mayoría casi 74 billones
alrededor de 23.000 millones de dólares
destinados a la renta básica por ello
los expertos durante la viabilidad para
llevar a cabo unas
las económicas tan ambiciosas a la luz
de la situación fiscal del país con un
49 2% de la población trabajando en la
informalidad y más del 42 por ciento de
la población en situación de pobreza
aquí hay que tener también un sentido de
responsabilidad por supuesto que la
sociedad los jóvenes que están marchando
tienen también los derechos para
solicitar algún tipo digamos de ayudas
por parte del gobierno la situación es
muy complicada a raíz de la pandemia la
caída del crecimiento económico el
deterioro del empleo especialmente para
los jóvenes que tienen tasas de
desempleo por encima del 24% pero
también ese tipo de propuestas tienen
que tener esa realidad fiscal en donde
colombia infortunadamente ha tenido
también una caída muy grande de sus
ingresos si bien el presupuesto del
comité está muy por encima de la fallida
reforma tributaria de casi 25 billones
de pesos colombianos
el comité difiere del gobierno y los
economistas tradicionales en la forma de
recaudar los fondos para estas ayudas
sociales proponen que la banca central
haga préstamos la monetización de las
reservas internacionales impuestos a los
más ricos
una apuesta por la producción nacional y
es que ante esta situación de protestas
y bloqueos de carreteras en colombia la
cámara de comercio de cali sitúa las
pérdidas económicas de las empresas en
aproximadamente 2 billones de pesos en
producción que equivale a casi 539
millones de dólares para hablar sobre el
costo económico del paro en el suelo
occidente de colombia saludo en este
momento a esteban piedrahita presidente
de la cámara de comercio de cali gracias
por estar aquí con nosotros en france 24
muy buena noche es muy buen día perdón
hablemos de casi 539 millones de dólares
en pérdidas en las empresas de la región
colombiana el valle del cauca
debido a esta paralización de la cadena
de producción por los bloqueos masivos
de las vías esto como afecta a la
población de cali y del resto del país y
además le pregunto cuál es el costo que
deben cargar los ciudadanos debido a
toda esta problemática
buenos dias raúl un saludo muy especial
a todos los televidentes de france
vancamp pues si hemos tenido dos semanas
muy complejas donde básicamente la
ciudad y todo el departamento han estado
bloqueados cambios la tercera ciudad de
colombia y el departamento del valle del
cauca donde nos ubicamos el tercer
departamento del país más o menos 5
millones de personas
pero además somos un gran abastecedor de
alimentos de medicamentos y de bienes de
higiene cuidado personal y del hogar a
colombia no solo porque tenemos una gran
potencia agroindustrial industrial y
productiva en la región sino también
porque aquí se ubica el principal puerto
del país de importación que es
buenaventura por donde entra el trigo la
soya
el maíz alimentos para tanto para
animales como para humanos entre otras
cosas entonces nosotros hicimos una
encuesta en 1700 empresas de todos los
tamaños micro pequeñas medianas grandes
y estimamos que en todos los sectores
más o menos el 70% de la producción está
parada porque pues si bien se puede más
o menos circular dentro de cali es ha
sido ha habido para cabellos bloqueos
indefinidos
en las entradas a la ciudad y también
los municipios que nos rodean y en el
paso al puerto entonces pues nosotros
estimamos que eso nos cuesta en dos
semanas
un poco más de dos puntos del pib en dos
semanas algo así como 700 millones de
dólares es un impacto grande para
nuestra región y también para el país
porque somos grandes abastecedores de
que muchos quieren tener primera
necesidad ahora esteban en cuánto tiempo
es tema de ustedes que se pueden
recuperar de estas millonarias pérdidas
y qué tan cuesta arriba será esta
recuperación que además ya venía
afectada por la pandemia
pues lo más triste es que tuvimos
obviamente un año muy malo el año pasado
la economía colombiana cayó más de un 7%
la la pobreza se disparó el desempleo
igualmente en cali tuvimos uno de los
mayores aumentos de pobreza si bien
tenemos niveles en el valle caride los
más bajos de pobreza del país tuvimos en
cali el mayor aumento de pobreza el año
pasado
sin embargo veníamos con una dinámica
bastante buena marzo el desempleo había
bajado considerablemente y hoy pues no
este año pues para recuperar las
pérdidas del año pasado teníamos que
crecer mucho no se estimaba crecimiento
para colombia el 5 del 6 con eso no
recuperamos el terreno perdido pero nos
acercábamos a 2019
pues ahora perdemos en dos semanas dos
puntos de ese crecimiento y esto pues
claro para las empresas es grave pero
sobre todo para los hogares hay gente
pasando anp y hemos perdido
89 mil personas se han dejado vacunar
por los bloqueos ahora las micros y
medianas empresas como se han visto
afectadas durante el conflicto en la
ciudad de cali y cómo es el panorama de
la economía en el valle del cauca las
próximas semanas
pues mire no muy afectadas porque las
cadenas de suministro no están
funcionando entonces ha habido algo de
abastecimiento de gasolina y de
alimentos algunos medicamentos en los
últimos días pero las plantas fábricas
granjas bodegas que abastecen a cali y
en buena parte de nuestro país están
cerradas entonces estamos aliviando un
poquito el abastecimiento del momento a
pesar de que los ciudadanos pues no se
pueden mover con facilidad etcétera pero
vamos a tener un grave problema muy
pronto porque se está muriendo pues
gallinas ponedoras de huevos en pollos
cerdos las cosechas no se pueden recoger
y tenemos pues todo el aparato
industrial básicamente parado y de nuevo
esto es un mayor impacto
en el empobrecimiento y a veces 26%
lamentablemente las empresas que
encuestamos esos aunque ya están
reduciendo empleos esteban gracias por
su tiempo por estar aquí con nosotros en
france 24 que tenga usted un feliz resto
de día estamos conversando con esteban
piedrahita presidente de la cámara de
comercio de cali para evaluar los costos
que ha tenido el paro en el departamento
el valle del cauca india supera ya las
250.000 muertes por koi 19 tras reportar
4 mil 205 muertes este miércoles un
nuevo récord diario la pandemia afecta
ahora especialmente a las zonas rurales
donde se agrava la precariedad del
sistema sanitario la falta de médicos de
unidades de cuidados intensivos y
también respiradores se traduce en
muertes evitables en las salas de
urgencias
escenas de desesperación y pánico en
este pequeño hospital de bis nor a 150
kilómetros de nueva delhi
los familiares intentan resucitar en
vano a una mujer que se quedó sin
oxígeno el doctor de turno en urgencias
no da abasto ante la afluencia de
pacientes y se ve obligado a dejar
algunos enfermos en manos de sus
acompañantes
ningún doctor acude a visitarnos nadie
nos dice que medicina dar a los
pacientes tenemos que ir a por el
oxígeno nosotros mismos el martes cuatro
personas murieron en la sala de
urgencias en una hora escasea el
material y las condiciones básicas de
higiene
hay tanto desorden pueden ver las
condiciones de la habitación como pueden
a recuperarse aquí
mientras que la incidencia parece
empezar a bajar en las grandes ciudades
preocupa el incesante colapso del
sistema sanitario en las zonas rurales
donde vive más del 60% de la población
no dejan de llegar pacientes de zonas
tanto rurales como urbanas hemos
involucrado a dos hospitales privados
no hay duda la cifra de personas
contagiadas es muy alta
mientras que en algunas zonas se empieza
a faltar madera para las tradicionales
incineraciones hindúes algunos cadáveres
son arrojados al ganges este miércoles
india registró el récord de 4 mil 205
muertes por kobe 19 en 20
horas
hasta que el informativo continúe con
nosotros
[Música]